este es el plato donde se celebrará el
debate presidencial francés para este
crucial cara a cara todo ha sido
acordado de antemano por las dos
campañas atrás queda la gran mesa que
compartieron emanuel marco imagen del
pen durante el debate de 2017 en su
lugar dos mesas más pequeñas una para
cada candidato separadas por dos metros
y medio los dos periodistas que moderan
estarán sentados juntos a cuatro metros
de distancia si te dice mundo interior
es muy diferente una entrevista y
realmente un trabajo papel de moderador
patronelli esquivo anteriores y luego
longás un periodista que quiere
entrevistar la prioridad es ser serio y
humilde un billete de mil sí pero tendrá
el debate un impacto en los votantes
no he hecho mi elección espero muchas
cosas espero detalles de los dos
candidatos
no cambiará mi decisión no veré más que
nada porque tengo curiosidad no para
decidirme realmente
yo no creo que lo vea porque no espero
mucho son dos candidatos que no me
gustan nada
para garantizar la imparcialidad los
candidatos han sorteado el lugar en el
que se sentarán en el plato y quien
hablará primero ma yinglin estará a la
derecha y comenzará al debate también se
ha acordado la temperatura del estudio
19 grados centígrados para evitar el
sudor en directo se utilizarán 16
cámaras para filmar el encuentro en 2017
16 millones y medio de franceses
siguieron el debate la cifra de
audiencia más baja desde 1974 los sips